it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
i am from newmarket the last time i
entered oh my god
yes we talked about how we were born in
the very same hospital so it's very nice
to see you again that's right um
i wanted to talk to you i know
everybody's probably asking you about
the stash but i think did you find out
if it was the same room yet
it might have been born in yeah i'm
hoping it was yeah
i guess some of that
energy um
the stash i think this could be the
first film that a stash had a slow-mo i
know it's incredible right yeah the
moustache to me is a outward
manifestation of pure evil and ego you
know
it's like a midlife crisis of its own
you know it's like buying a sports car
at 55 you know what i mean
what car equivalent is it is it like a
lamborghini is it a cub
it was an early uber
it was so good but i heard you thought
that it wasn't actually big enough uh
number one are we going to go bigger in
the next film do you have any ideas for
where you will go with the next one and
how do you achieve the perfect stash and
when you shoot that slow-mo do you like
do you sort of tweak it knowing it's
going to be a slo-mo well no one can say
what the future holds but i but i uh i i
lobbied constantly to make the the
mustache bigger i i literally wanted it
to leave frame on both sides you know
i wanted i wanted it to be leaving frame
on both sides and then it would start to
move up and down and you'd realize that
as the camera widened out that it's
become uh seesaw and sonic's on one end
and knuckles is on the other
you need to have a remote control guy in
the next one that like can move it move
it up and down and sideways incredible
and the whole thing um as a canadian i
appreciated the kilometers to miles joke
i don't know if that was an improvised
but thank you for that yeah that was uh
that was a last-minute ad for sure well
i wanted to ask you about that because
obviously you have always reaching out
psychically
there you go
but you obviously
you know you have a bigger role in this
film you have a different character arc
can you sort of talk about like how much
jim carrey is on the cutting room floor
like how much free reign did you get to
just go and go and go i know you said
you you would go all night if you could
and keep going it's like a wonderful
relationship that eventually breaks your
heart you know what i mean it's just
like fantastic creativity and amazing
output and i carpet bomb i just come in
with so much stuff and i just i never
leave myself alone by the end of the
movie i'm so exhausted i never want to
work again and what happens is to every
hundred ideas i give them or i practice
or if or i play around with
you know ten stay in the movie
and you know or five
two of them are something that you might
never have seen before you know so
that's how i work i just literally throw
everything in the kitchen sink at it and
and uh
inevitably i'm heartbroken about some
things that aren't going to be in the
movie you know really oh that's
interesting
yeah like the word numero ultra
microscopic silicone volcano koniosis
i've been trying to get that in both
movies
and so far it hasn't made it into the
movie
you know
it's a lung disease
maybe third time's a charm who knows
yeah keep at it you never you never know
right but is there what was the moment
on the oh contraire my friend the one
that actually did make it in the movie
that you were super happy about yeah
that's my french lessons when i was
growing up in canada
it wasn't that's all that's all that
stayed
that and cela garage de paul
we sailed a garage depart
we looked at rush to paul
i do right mr mugs goes to the moon did
they teach you that in school
yeah oh yeah
i know i learned to read reading mr mugs
goes to the moon
um
the fans of this i mean you've obviously
had fans your whole career but can you
sort of talk about were you surprised at
how people reacted to the first one and
how they're already reacting i know i
tweeted a reaction i love the second one
were you surprised at how much
fan outreach and what is the sonic
community like and different from maybe
other fans other films you've worked on
well gamers love their games and if you
if you hit it right it's they they love
you forever i mean they they don't give
up what they love you know so and if you
do it wrong they'll tell you so real
quick yeah you know they're very
passionate about it because it's a part
of them you know it's like part of their
dna
you know when they get attached to these
games it's kind of a different universe
and it's a little bit of a
responsibility but uh i have undying
faith in uh the creative process and
that if my heart's coming from the right
place that i more more often than not
will hit the same place in them
and uh and that's kind of how i operate
you know it's like you know there's no
denying joy
you know and if i have joy when i'm
doing it it's gonna translate it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna grab them
because
they want it
yeah um robotnik at the very beginning
of this film
is banished to mushroom planet yes you
can only eat and drink mushrooms if you
jim carrey could only eat one food if
you were banished to a planet you could
only eat one food for the rest of your
life what would it be
grilled cheese sandwiches that's a great
answer yeah grilled cheese sandwiches
dipped in ketchup
or ketchup chips
which is uniquely canadian
ketchup chips here let me see what else
what else is canadian that we can't get
down here a crunchy chocolate bars
um a big turk
big turk is an amazing chocolate bar
uh and uh let me see uh but you know the
thing about the mushroom planet is he he
obviously sustained life on the mushroom
planet but he he obviously didn't find
the right kind of mushrooms because if
he had he would have stayed there
that is true
i think there must have been a scene and
i'm not spoiling anything because it was
in the trailer where did you do wire
work in this film because you're sort of
like projected can you talk about when
you get your superpowers sort of
exploring those moments and being on a
wire what does jim carry on a wire look
like as he's filming miserable
uh you know it's one of those things
where the way they shot they put a psych
behind me and they projected things onto
it it wasn't going to be the finished
product but they really gave me
something that gave me the idea of the
energy of the piece right and i was kind
of inside
a crude version of the mech head so i
could see
kind of where i was and what i was doing
at first it was just going to be him
standing at a podium or or uh sitting in
a chair
and i said no he's quantum at this point
he doesn't need to sit or stand
he's going to be
we got to suspend him in midair he's got
to be suspended by the power of the
tesla coils
and uh and controlling this thing with
his mind his voice and his body you know
and all of it is connected he's now one
with the machine you know and that was a
blast so i knew what it i knew it was
going to be something super cool in the
end so that helped me endure the
crushing of my genitalia
[Laughter]
and that's where i'm being wrapped
that's the best sorry
didn't mean i didn't mean to be crude
but that's just the scientific truth
you
there will remain in
more children
you remain a national treasure i just
love chatting with you congratulations i
love the nation that i am a treasure too
thank you
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
so first i wanted to ask you a very
hard-hitting question at the very
beginning of this movie robotnik is
stuck on mushroom island he can only eat
drink sleep mushrooms if you could only
eat one food for the rest of your life
which food would you choose
sushi oh
very interesting i would say
if there's no repercussions i would say
cheeseburgers if there's no
repercussions of how much i'm eating and
also no earth repercussions of eating
cheese it's not on a magic cheeseburger
island
that would be a magic cheeseburger if
you want no repercussions yeah i guess
you're right yeah true i mean you'd be
by yourself you would just be you know
ensconced in cheeseburgers um great
answers by the way um so obviously you
both go on sort of your own journey in
this film but you are still the most
iconic duo you're so good together where
do you both think the characters fit in
in the pantheon of great buddies in the
history of film where would you rank
them and what do you think they're sort
of similar to
um oh there's mike and sully and monster
zane mike intel is a great one yeah mel
gibson and danny glover and lethal very
different one that uh harry and lloyd
and dumb and dumber that's an incredible
one to punch i guess i mean listen tom
tom and sonic have to be in the upper
1000 buddies of all time
have to be
in the rankings you're a safe bet i
think so right yeah yeah
pick a specific number are we going 9.99
are we going low hundreds i'm going i'm
gonna go oh i'm gonna go 463.
okay okay what about you
james i'm gonna say it's i'm gonna give
us a little more credit say we're in the
300s wow i like wow that's good
that's a good one that's a good one i
would give you i would do even better um
obviously fans love this franchise fans
are so excited i tweeted a reaction to
this film and i can't believe how the
love i got
for you are you shocked by the love
still that fans what has been like a
favorite sort of moment
and like even this film people are
already so hyped for it and loving it
i mean i love that the you know
the whole redesign thing on the first
film right like they that said a lot
when when um jeff the director was like
you know and i think it was a whole a
lot of us but
we listened to the fans and it was one
of those moments where they felt really
heard and seen and um
i don't know i i i'm very proud of the
movie i think the movie is a terrific
film but i think that that actually
carried a lot of weight and um it was
not lost on us this time around to get
that right as well
you know you want to cater to the fans
and you want to figure out a way of also
you know bringing sonic to people who've
never played the game or don't know who
he is um but um but yeah i think that
was an important thing and and one of
the reasons why i think it's doing as
well as it has i think one of the one of
the most exciting things was we got to
drop in on some audiences which is very
very exciting and when tails was
revealed in that first movie to watch
the audience go crazy like the marvel
movie just had a reveal at the end
segment was so cool
because you're like oh they not only
have do they care about it but they like
want more and they love these characters
there's so much more you can play with
here but uh the fans reacting has been
so
lovely there's even like videos of
people online watching the trailer for
the first time and getting so excited
and you just feel lucky to be a part of
that world trademark little mermaid
it's so cool it's actually really cool
it's nice to have love in the world
for the rest of it right um speaking of
tales ben
how did you because i know you and
colleen actually got to film together
you got to do a lot of virtual stuff i
don't know if you worked with idris as
well um but so how did you develop that
chemistry together um and how did you
make sure you got that relationship
right yes so colleen is obviously a
super pro at vo she's done a billion
different voice over roles she's an
unbelievable human and actress and uh
for me it was just we want to get on a
zoom together and record the first
couple scenes so there's like a
like um a bar type scene that we did
together and the whole idea is for her
to kind of feel what the what the
feeling is in this movie because she's
done so many different iterations of
tales and how it works out and then also
to see how we play together and how we
can joke around and how we can build on
the relationship and it was so lovely to
be able to do that with her because we
really are a team uh in this movie we're
like teammates so she was incredible and
then i haven't gotten to do anything
with interest yet which is kind of
amazing because we're kind of like
against each other so it's makes even
more sense but it's like that you're
like
we're like this this is now this is us
fighting in the movie so he goes
fighting in the movie um so it's been
it's been very very very exciting and
watching
him prove how good of a voiceover actor
he is is pretty remarkable because you
could be a good actor and be a terrible
voice-over actor but he's good at both
and then james the last time i talked to
you for the first one i said you're the
best tennis ball actor in the business
because i always believe that you're
really talking to sonic it continued in
this one i'm always looking i'm always
looking to see if you know every actor
if they get it wrong or they or they get
it right but i wanted to ask you like
when you're picturing when you're
looking at the tennis ball and you're
looking are you actually picturing sonic
do you ever picture button do you ever
see again does he see people
i do
sometimes i do because i mean
sitting here with ben it's like
obviously he brings so much of his own
you know magnetic
personality to the character but um
i mean we saw this video game character
come to life through ben and so when i
do those scenes i imagine i hear his
voice i see him sometimes if i you know
especially if i'm sitting there
different iterations like sometimes it's
a piece of tape sometimes it's a tennis
ball sometimes it's a
like a stuffed animal and the stuffed
animal it's hard to hear your voice if
i'm looking at the tape okay if i hear
this if i see the stuffed animal you
know i i hear ben's voice in my head and
i was always really a stickler for the
the technical i liked the challenge of
it i didn't i was always like i'm not
going to just be staring at this in this
direction because i see so many of these
movies
i have three kids and it bothers me it
sort of takes me out of the movie when
it's not
it doesn't really look like you're
looking at him so there's this thing
called triangulation where if he's
closer of course your eyes are doing
this instead of that and i really wanted
to make sure that that was right um and
and then it just felt like you're
talking to ben
it shouldn't feel like you're talking to
you know an animated hedgehog it should
just feel like you're talking to a pal
so um i've counted i actually counted
eight before but now i think there's
nine duos in this film there's so many
good duos like you know you've got sonic
tail tom sonic and tails robotnik and
stone robotnik and knuckles i'm not
going to list them all but who do you
both think is the best duo in this film
you're going to have mixed emotions
maybe whoa
i mean it's cool to see natasha and
tikka have their i
love that action sequence in this one
and that was that i agree i think james
nailed it on that yeah that scene is
amazing they're both incredible and
natasha is an action star it's
incredible yeah um now that you're both
sonic sonic aficionados
next film who would you like to see a
crossover with what video game crossover
would you love to see in sonic
numero 3. we can pick any video game yes
oh my goodness this would be exciting
that's interesting i would love if there
was a way to introduce a character
that's in a video game called smash
brothers because then all of us can have
big epic fights with each other so i'm
gonna say like uh
um
mega man or something like that
or like um
that would be really fun or like um
donkey kong it would be crazy if someone
just was there like you're like what
donkey kong would be amazing even though
it's nintendo that'd be amazing oh right
yeah yeah
pitfall
would also be fun to see cyclops from
x-men in it
beautiful
who are you
where
are my manners
sonic
meet
knuckles i love that i get to talk to
you the week that this movie comes out
because
a lot of sonic fans have already seen
this movie critics have seen this movie
they're talking about how funny you are
in this you're a scene stealer are you
like
whoo
because this is nice you know
it's a big character
the pressure was on you know the
pressure was on i'm not joking the first
movie is great right the first movie and
then you know the sequels have to live
up to the first movie but not to mention
introducing a beloved character that
everyone wants to be like okay he better
be good so
thank you i'm really pleased that the
fans and literally the sonic fans are
sort of responding well to it i'm really
happy about that yeah no i can imagine
now it's my understanding because i
heard you talk about this in another
interview that when you were actually in
the recording booth i want to break this
down a little bit that to sort of get
the cadence right you were reading other
people's parts like you were maybe
reading the lines of sonic and then you
were reading your own parts are you
doing that in the sonic voice are you
doing it in your own voice feel free to
demonstrate i wouldn't be mad at you
feel free to demonstrate no i don't want
to see that but no just to get like you
know the back and forth because
obviously
all of it was shot in piecemeal you know
the live action was shot ben uh his
performance was recorded separately and
mine too so it was all put together as a
jigsaw and sometimes just to get that
interaction i would be like sonic will
say
you for someone you know i'm now i'm now
i'm actually gonna do it for you he's
like for someone called knuckles you
sure are a bad puncher and i'm like
and so you know i just need to hear
myself do it or hear what it might sound
like to just you know land the timing
properly um but please
do not repeat that impression of ben
schwartz he's terrible
you made my week that was incredible
actually you're a very good sonic you're
a great knuckles you're a very good
sonic too i did try knuckles in a
high-pitched voice and they didn't go
for that can you imagine no i heard
about this so how many voices did you
actually try like was there just sort of
a couple iterations or how many do you
go through you walking around the house
trying different things is your family
like what's happening right now what's
going on here who are you talking to not
talking to everyone
i would i would do that in the initial
stages and then when we got into the
room and we discussed it you know three
or four different voices but the
high-pitched one
you know that didn't go down well you
know they were like
no way are you doing that voice so you
know we quickly moved on and got to
where we are now but that's fun it's fun
to try different things i know i did at
one point i i auditioned for voice overs
and i know you learned that you have
voices in you that you didn't know you
had like how many have you sort of
locked away for other roles down the
road oh like i have a nice little
catalog of different voices and and
accents and cadences cadences is my
thing you know like with sonic i mean
with sonic he's like a motor mouth right
he speaks very quickly you can say it
all in one but with uh
knuckles we loved that he was so
stupid so you know
and i enjoyed playing that
yeah no you could tell the joy the joy
came through the screen it like left off
the screen um i don't know how much um
gaming you've done in your life but do
you know what a cheat code is yes i do
yes i've done quite a bit of gaming
yeah if i gave you a cheat code in life
and for people who don't know what it is
it can unlock power you could be a
different character for a day or for a
period of time or whatever what would
you use your cheat code for in life
my chico would uh be to teleport i would
like
and end up somewhere else i don't know
what the noise was the ch
it's kind of like the
mechanisms of the cheat code working but
that's what i would do is to be able to
teleport how many weird voices actually
reminded me of something how many weird
sort of sound effects do you have to do
when you're recording because i know
you've recorded many you know you've
done voice work many times in the past
how many times are you just like
grunting doing like weird stuff where
you're just gonna have to create these
like sound effects that especially for a
video game character yeah you do i mean
like in the sequence of a voice-over
session you do the voice-over work the
lines
and then you do
the
the grunt work so like if you're getting
hit
oh
you do that little section and then you
do the loud ones because you lose your
voice if you do the loud ones first you
can't do your lines so that's the
sequence but the crazy thing is when
you're doing the fight sequence stuff to
get the right sound you know like uh you
know try it
yeah that's getting punched in the
stomach yeah dude
it was okay it wasn't a hard hit
that was a real hard hit this one
yeah there you go
yeah i know you feel silly right but you
have to do that a million times yeah
just one more please just a little more
and a little less
now i can say that idris elba has
directed me i'm very excited about that
um congratulations i know there's going
to be a tv series what is the vibe of
the series or what do you hope the vibe
of the series is going to be wow okay so
um first of all um
the tv show is too early to say at the
moment i'm uh i'm i don't know what
they're planning but
my understanding is that you know like
knuckles is a fish out of water you know
he's kind of like he's like a traveler
and england and england in the world is
like wow this is kind of interesting so
i kind of like him you know going to
different restaurants and tasting food
and you know
doing touristy things
i just want to see knuckles at you know
statue of liberty going what is this you
know i mean that's what i think but i
think they'll have more adventures than
that i think i heard that you when you
were doing some of your recordings that
you actually already saw jim's
performance was already in the can and
you sort of did you get to sort of watch
it in its entirety or are you watching
it and then feeding off of like lines in
the moment with jim cause that must have
been cool yeah we took it apart we
dissected it i didn't watch the whole
thing i just took it apart and we just
you know circulated a scene because it's
quite it's you know obviously movie
magic and editing and all of that but
you do have to get a sense that they're
in the same room
so i go watch it and i was always
interested in who was reading my lines
to jim carrey you know
i was always interested in who that guy
was or what that was but in any case i
never really got to listen to that and
then i would fill in the blanks so it's
quite it's quite interesting because i
love jim carrey i really wanted to work
with him but uh
okay this is what we're gonna do step
one light taunting step two i have no
idea
i know we saw tails at the end of the
first sonic but when you got the call
and you were they were like you're going
to play
were you like
i mean you've played this character for
so many years on tv and in the game i
know it was more of like really
like it better be mean if it's not me
no well i mean as a voice actor you
don't expect it you know we get replaced
so often by celebrities so
that that i got to do this movie i was
thrilled and just so so very excited so
tails i mean everybody
who loves the games loves tales they
love that relationship between tales and
sonic but after playing this character
for so many years who is tails to you
like i know what tails means to fans but
who how have you personally connected
with tails he's the best best friend
you're ever gonna have he's so smart
he's so dear he's loyal he's got um
you know he's got energy he's he's going
to be there for you no matter what
did you have any did you were you and
ben able to have conversations before
you started filming and sort of build
the chemistry
no no no we did get to work together but
we didn't have any contact beforehand so
we just you know
throw you in the pool and see you know
but it was it was so wonderful he's such
a you know he's such a great actor he's
so funny he has such an extensive improv
background and i have a fair amount of
improv background as well so working off
of him was it was easy and and wonderful
and
the you know the relationship really
went from there so you did travel
together you were able to be like in the
voice recording booth together and do a
lot of that we were doing it virtually
yeah yeah yeah oh my gosh that's amazing
because you don't have to get that right
so that must change the dynamic for you
like what do what do you think because
people just love him
as sonic he's like the perfect sonic so
sort of can you talk about like why you
feel he's the perfect sonic and sort of
working opposite him what did he bring
that kind of you know maybe you hadn't
explored before
he has so much energy let's just start
with that and like you know sonic is his
thing is speed and ben you know he's a
fast talker too and so it just it just
works you know he i think he is sonic
seriously and i you know the like i said
you know the funny and like having all
the improv background and it's just it
just works like he is he's really
perfect to play this role
can you maybe tell me like what was a
moment or a uh in sort of like your
virtual sessions that kind of stands out
that was like oh this i'm going to take
this one away with me and
lock that memory up
oh all of it but um the scene in siberia
was such a blast i mean they really kind
of let us you know we we did the you
know we stuck to the script and then
they kind of just let us go and to have
that give and take with him was
fantastic i mean it really was so so so
much fun um it was just it was brilliant
it was fantastic i think it might be my
favorite scene in the movie it's so
funny
yeah because it's also like a you know
it's a it takes you out like there's so
much going on but then yeah like that
moment of comic relief like they had
that in the first one and this yeah
they've they've upped the ante so you've
you've voiced another sonic character in
the past charmybee yes would you like to
see charmy b
in the next sonic movie would you like
to sort of maybe play both
that would be fantastic i never even
thought of that that would be great yeah
i would love that that would be so
interesting because he's a in a similar
range-ish detail so i'd have to kind of
really
concentrate
i'd have to really think clearly about
their characters and and where they
would be headed yeah really so you have
to like differentiate like in your mind
because i'm wondering for you like when
you first if you can go back to like the
first time
you played this character how do you
because there's so much charm there's so
much love how did you find the voice in
the beginning like how long did that
take and then for this film
can you sort of jump back into it or is
it do you really have to sort of warm up
to it
i can jump back in i for whatever reason
tails is just this piece of me that i
can find um
initially i'm really i'm a visual person
so for me when i approach any new
character it helps me to have a picture
um so i i look at him and and then i
give him what what my interpretation is
and also they'll give me a character
description so from what they've given
me and the picture then i come up with
what i think the character sounds like
and who that character is and then as
you work on it with a director in
whatever given situation that the
character is in the character develops
over time so i'm sure if you listen to
the first episode of sonic boom and like
the most recent video game it probably
sounds a little bit different because of
the progression that the character has
taken and also this movie same thing so
how many iterations of the voice do you
think you did before you sort of arrived
on
like the final
not many i think it's just it's more of
like an evolution that you don't really
notice like i didn't do anything
consciously to change it it's more about
like you know his maturity level or his
um groundedness or whatever situation
that he's in
yeah what did you um
because you have played this character
in different iterations
doing a film where you're playing this
character what sort of aspects of tales
did you get to explore that you hadn't
gotten to do before
so since it's the beginning of the
relationship with sonic um very much
this like fanboy um you know sonic is
his idol you know he definitely doesn't
see them as equals um whereas in the
past they were they were certainly
closer to equals i mean he's always been
considered the sidekick but their
friendship
had been so solidly established that i
don't think he felt you know
lesser and not that he feels lesser he's
just like he's so in awe of him and
that's his idol you know um and that
sonic would take him in and consider him
a friend is just
thrilling for him you know he can't
believe it like sonic the hedgehog is
going to be my bff what like that's
crazy to him yeah
so fans obviously and i just got a
little taste of it because i tweeted out
a reaction of my love for sonic 2 and
there was so much fan support what has
been sort of over the years what is the
question fans sort of ask you most what
is the request you get the most and sort
of
is there a moment like a standout moment
with fans and how much they love you
your portrayal in this character well
let me just start with the sonic fans
are like they're the best fans in the
world and they are true blue fans
seriously and no pun intended with the
blue but seriously they absolutely love
this franchise and the love that they
have
poured on me has been
astonishing and i'm i'm and i'm feeling
it in every you know they've been so
supportive of me continuing the role
they're so excited and i'm so grateful
for that they're the best fans in the
world um
truly i mean they really really are and
it's it's been so lovely to see and so
some of the fan moments that have stood
out for me um we did a convention
in new york with the cast of sonic boom
and i didn't know as much about this
universe then as i do now i learned so
this guy this kid came up with like an
encyclopedia of sonic and he showed me
and that's when i learned his full name
i'd been i'd recorded an entire season
of the show thinking his name was just
tails and a fan told me his name was
miles tails brower
that's amazing yeah i'm like how did you
guys not tell me this well
one element of the games because
obviously you're so familiar with the
games what element of the games that
they brought to this film because they
really made an effort i think in the
sequel to make it feel more like a video
game what were sort of your favorite
elements or easter eggs that they
brought to this one i don't wanna i want
them to be able to find them themselves
yeah
but really keep an eye out in the temple
because that is like
like easter egg central um and it was so
beautifully done and you know like it's
like being in a video game but not in in
a movie and it just made sense the way
that they did it just was seamless
really trust me there will come a moment
when your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah first of all i just talked to jim
and he was telling me about just
how much he shoots like how much you
sort of let him go with it he
appreciates that a lot of the actors
have expressed that how many minutes of
extra footage are on the cutting room
floor of jim carrey's performance like
could you make a feature-length film off
of it oh not not quite a feature link
but probably definitely a mini series uh
i mean it's it's incredible he he brings
so many ideas to set he cares so much
about getting robotnik right uh i mean
he calls me on the weekends we talk
through the scenes that we'll be filming
that week he has pitches it's just it's
incredible to have a guy like jim carrey
who's made so many films he's he's done
so much but he still cares so deeply
still shows up works so hard um and yeah
unfortunately you can't all make the
movie but i have no doubt that we'll
find a way for for fans and audiences to
kind of get a look at some of that stuff
uh down the line he told me twice now
two movies there's like a map
an amalgamation of words he's strung
together it sounded like
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious to me
he says it hasn't made it in yet why has
it nominated yet well because it would
add 12 minutes to the running link it's
not it's that long of a word no it's the
longest word in the english language i
believe and i've heard it many many
times and yet i'm not even going to
attempt it i'm not even going to
embarrass myself uh yeah but but again
we filmed it we edited it it's a scene
it's it's hilarious uh so yeah we'll
we'll we'll make sure that it's out
there just so jim can finally put that
one to rest he should not be walking
around with that word rattling around
his head
um i think what really works about this
film and in so many film franchises is
when
the the director truly has a passion for
the project that he's working on and a
true understanding of it but what was
the challenge i mean you're bringing in
two beloved
characters tails and knuckles and you
really it seemed like i mean this the
the animation was so incredible in the
first one but it feels like you even
upped the ante and you made it even
better in this one and that's what a lot
of fans are saying so sort of from a
physical perspective and in more of an
emotional getting that balance those
relationships right what was the
challenge for you bringing those
characters to screen oh just that it is
a much bigger movie and a bigger story
but in all the ways that that i love i
mean i come from from visual effects in
my background i started my career as a
character animator i love doing
animation i love working with animators
to to create these performances so
being able to bring in tails and
knuckles and of course tails who we
teased at the end of the first film to
see audiences react so positively i mean
i was in theaters where kids are
literally just yelling at this at the
screen like it's you know the beatles on
ed sullivan i mean it was incredible and
like gave us so much sort of wind in our
sails so much great momentum and we just
took that all right into
the sequel and to filming and and yeah
it just carried us through every step of
the way so for those hardcore fans those
true blue sonic fans what uh give me one
easter egg that you can we can tease to
them that they you know from legacy
sonic that they're gonna see in this
film
oh there's so many honestly uh my
favorite i'll just tell you what my
favorite is and that's hands down is the
the tornado the red biplane of course
it's all over the place on billboards on
the posters but it's such an iconic
image of tails flying sonic into battle
on the wing of the of the red biplane uh
that was something just very early on we
knew we have to get this into the movie
it's just going to give fans just
goosebumps to see that on the big screen
uh from you know almost 30 years ago i
mean sonic 2 it's just such a
a key just an iconic visual so so
excited that we were able to do it for
this film
what were some of the other things that
were so important to you to bring into
this because this is like you said it's
a totally new world everything's bigger
everything's bolder what were sort of
some of the elements that you know when
you were sort of beginning to craft this
movie that were the most important to
you to bring to this oh just to build on
what we've done in the first film i mean
that movie was all about sonic getting
uh finding friend finding a family we
ended that movie with a family right
with sonic and tom and maddie sitting up
there in the attic together and one
thing we knew we couldn't lose sight on
is that was something that really
resonated with audiences and families
they really connected to those
characters emotionally so as excited as
i was about bringing in new characters
and and doing a much bigger movie and a
much bigger story we had to sort of keep
that as our sort of the foundation you
maintain that as just uh uh knowing how
important that was uh to audiences and
then how strongly they responded that
from the first film were you surprised
at how excited people were that the
poster for the movie looked like the
video game cover like people were so
excited it's fantastic i i i
called our marketing team and i was like
oh my god i don't know if you guys are
doing a print run of this but i need
them now like immediately it's such a
cool such a cool image everyone on on
the on paramount side all the marketing
team they're all fans and you see it
like you see it in the work and everyone
loves sonic loves this world loves these
movies and that comes through and all
the work and all the marketing and it's
just great i just feel like i i'm so
thankful to be a part of this team
do you look at this film like as you're
building it do you look at it as part of
a trilogy in terms of setting it up and
like i know they've greenlit the final
one or the third sonic do you look at it
as a trilogy and so how are you looking
forward into the future of sonic i i
don't think we've ever sort of limited
ourselves in terms of oh this is going
to be a three film arc i think we're
just really having a great time going
movie to movie of course you can't help
but sort of start to to be thinking
about other story lines or characters as
you're working on you know
a number two or as we did in number one
i mean the image of the master armhole
that's on sonic's uh the map that
longclaw gave him i mean we we
purposefully put that in in the first
movie having no idea
where we gonna get to do more movies but
it's like hey we'll put this here we'll
seed it um it'll be there if we need it
uh and we got to we got to take
advantage of that so uh it's so fun uh
to to sort of imagine where it could go
from here um but but there isn't a
specific trilogy uh uh in mind i guess
would be the answer to that question if
you could explore a crossover of sonic
and any other video game what would it
be
um
i mean the the the smash brothers thing
is kind of amazing the idea of that we
just throw all these video game
characters into a battle royale and just
see who's there at the end of it so uh
we've
i know ben uh has joked about that from
time to time but a smash brothers uh
initiative
is kind of hilarious
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
so i'm asking everybody today because in
this film you know the original film we
obviously had sonic and tom they were
great duo this film we have sonic and
tales i think the two of you
make a great duo you also have your
significant others
who do you both think is the best duo
the number one best duo in this film and
i'm gonna tell you what ben and james
said in a second whoo
can we choose ourselves
okay great i was going to be like
yeah
can we choose ourselves yeah when they
say self-love and self-care that's right
let's flip we're choosing us we're
keeping up
as you absolutely should and i will tell
you that ben and james also picked the
two of you
oh
[Laughter]
well i'm going this energy right here is
amazing and i know you brought a lot of
you've both done so much improv you're
both great improvers did you get to do
it seemed like you got to do more of it
in this film um was that the case and
how did it work on the day when you're
shooting the portal scene because the
portal scene is so such madness i mean i
feel so lucky uh when i get to work with
the director that gives us room to play
and jeff is that director like we
obviously
definitely respect the script and get
you know shots as written but you know
we come up with ideas in the moment and
he really allows us to play and on that
day specifically we're doing it on
a very hot day in hawaii but we're
standing on you know
ice the snow machine so it's like our
feet were frozen but we were hot but we
were hot and then we're also playing
around so it was just the best kind of
controlled chaos you can imagine
that's really fun hawaii
i think it was so much fun it was oh my
god and then for tika for you anything
that you wanted to because you got to do
so much more action in this film and
sort of physical that physical comedy
yeah i mean
i got to play with natasha rothlow who
is my sister and so it's it was exciting
that we were
you know used more and used as action
figures and and superheroes and and not
being um
you know we weren't the ones who needed
the help right uh and it was exciting to
come together and
and kick butt
okay so if sonic sonic started like
failing himself at the beginning of this
movie he calls himself a superhero named
blue justice
if you're giving yourselves a superhero
name what is it
oh
um
maddie the marker no maddie the
magnificent there you go love it
i would be uh
rachel the rebel
oh i like this that's right and we're
under the sonic sirens yes
that is our duo the sonic sirens
uh one thing that i thought was really
cool like jim carrey's stash got a
slow-mo in this movie you both got a lot
of shots that were you know slowed down
for the final version which adds so much
to the humor of it do you know on the
day that what you're filming is going to
be a slow-mo and do you tweak your
performance like when you're doing that
yes luckily we know because jeff has
such a specific vision for these moments
and for me it was reminding myself that
they're going to slow it down in the
edit so i don't have to walk like this
in real life
so that was i learned that real quick um
and uh yeah it was just really cool to
see
how he added you know the texture of
that in the final cut
and it makes it so much more dramatic
and funny
oh my god some of my favorite scenes in
the movie like i love a destination
movie in general i love watching a
destination movie and then the fact that
they added that layer to this film so
because you were both in the first one
can you sort of just compare filming
because it must have been a very
different filming experience from the it
was we weren't in the pandemic one for
the first one we were just kind of you
know
talking out loud seeing each other's
faces on each other it was great and
then the pandemic happened and but the
great thing that they created you know
especially paramount and and jeff is
like we were in our own little bubble
right and we had great support the crew
was incredible everybody was being
flexible and um we had a really good
time we were happy to be working and
doing it safely so it was definitely
very different but
um
it was play it was like child's play
yeah and i think too just like you know
story-wise i mean i was tied up for most
of the first movie so i'd go from doing
you know literally nothing
to everything and it wasn't nothing i
made an impact
i had a big impact i did i did i pissed
my stuff no i'm good
in a chair with my daughter running
around um but no i think what the joy
for me was just to see our characters
develop and we really get to see
sisterhood on display oh i loved the
sisterhood i thought this sisterhood was
absolutely brilliant natasha i know
you're also a writer
i'm wondering if you were going to write
a crossover film between white lotus
and sonic
how's that going
sonic
sonic meets us at the beach like this
i'm just imagining uh jennifer's
character tanya and sonic meeting in the
spa
and just her being non-plussed about it
like she wouldn't even notice that it's
an animated character that's you know
having a cup of tea and getting a
massage um one day i want maybe maybe
i'll write i'll work on some other
things but i'll put that on the list
um can you talk about a little bit about
how
the sonic fans have been with you guys
like sonic fans are like nothing else it
feels like what has been sort of the
reaction from the first one and also
people have already like trickling a few
people have had a sneak peek i love the
film sort of the reaction from fans what
it sort of meant to you
you know any time people show up for you
in this industry it's and they blow you
away by how much they show up
we're just grateful because these fans
are die hard they grew up with sonic
they're bringing their kids to sonic
they're bringing their nieces their
nephews everybody to sonic and we i'm
just blown away and just so grateful to
them and i can't believe it yeah it's
wild it's really overwhelming i think
that like they're very opinionated for
sure we saw you know right before the
first one came out they have thoughts um
they have notes they have notes and
thoughts but it comes from a place of
love like they just
it's so precious to them and i think
what really is important is that you
know jeff is a fan first and wants to
protect it for everyone and
just to see their response to the care
and uh you know that he's given the film
is really beautiful to see
if either of you could i don't know if
you're big gamers or not but if you
could choose for sonic 3 a crossover
with sonic with any video game
from ever what would you choose
oh my goodness maybe sonic and zelda
oh that would be cool
i see i mean i feel like sonic and yoshi
would just like have a good time
you know what i mean like they would i
mean they're too young for brewski's but
they had like you know a sprite and
really get a giggle on yoshi would be
like please get off my back get off my
back i think that'd be cute
discovered the source of ultimate power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you bought some kind of
space porcupine so first of all you are
such a great stone
fans have so embraced you and that
relationship between stone and robotnik
i saw on your twitter there was
something about somebody like fans right
send you homages all the time there was
something set to eminem that you
retweeted
can you just talk about what it's meant
to you as an actor to have that support
and love from the sonic community
um i've been
i just i constantly am reminded of how
fortunate i am uh and i'm so grateful
for it i mean to see
so many fans hop on board and appreciate
stone
and show me so much love too is it's
really quite
overwhelming and in a positive way you
know yes uh i think i think it's a nice
reminder of how
how great the world can be and how and
how uh how much love there is in the
world
speaking of love jim carrey so amazing
you've now had two films to develop
you know that relationship how do you
sort of balance that because he's even
more maniacal this time around how do
you play the perfect sidekick like how
do you balance the energy and create
that for yourself i think agent stone is
the grounding element to dr robotnik so
i think with how big dr robotnik can be
i think agent stone always brings that
like human perspective or audience
perspective and grounding element to it
so what i love about agent stone too is
is
his um
undying support of robotnik but also his
judgment at times like you'll catch a
moment where he'll he'll be like i don't
i don't know what that was but okay
let's keep going like you know what i
mean okay but my favorite element is
like the moment that robotnik walks in
to the mean bean and the look of love in
your eyes like puppy dog where do you
put yourself to film those scenes is it
just like art imitates life like
complete adoration for jim carrey or how
do you sort of where do you put your
head i mean there's definitely a little
bit of that for sure right like i think
it's it's it's not the hardest to kind
of you know
realize the situation that i as an actor
am in and how
incredible it is and like my wildest
dreams
you know wouldn't have come true and um
but it's also i mean it's
agent stone is is really fun to play and
it's quite easy to put yourself in a
place of um
such positivity i think agent stone is
like such a positive type of character
which we're not used to seeing in a
quote-unquote villain
type role
nailed it that's exactly what it is so
i'm going to ask everybody today there
are i've counted eight duos
like different combinations of duos in
this film who is the best duo in your
opinion
in the movie
yes okay selfishly i gotta go stone and
robotnik okay okay that's because as a
fan uh i oh man
i do really
love
the
um the dynamic between sonic and tails
and getting getting to see that for the
first time on the big screen live action
as a fan it's it's so good and then you
add the the knuckles element as like a
you know that power coming in and idris
and and knuckles just like
that he's so good so good
knuckles personality in this is so great
i was laughing so hard
so good i loved the scene where you have
the handshake and i mean you you have to
do a lot of you know the tennis ball
acting in that yeah i want to talk about
like the physical comedy and how did you
sort of achieve that moment like what
are you actually holding are you holding
on to anything when you're doing like
the fake handshake are you just putting
your hand out or how does it work yeah
so so basically it was we had a kind of
life-size model there uh and i think we
did one take with the life-size model to
just get an idea of where eye lines and
my hand would go and everything and then
uh remove the model and then it was kind
of just remembering over and over
roughly where
uh where my hand would be the height
and then just
you know imagine
use your imagination go back to the
child days wild imagination and uh i
think we did a bunch of different takes
of like how to what kind of
like is it gonna look like this is it
gonna look like squi it was
i i think we did like 12 takes of
different kind of hand
crushing gestures
i understand if i did a beer commercial
once and holding the fake beer because
the beer had to fly at me i couldn't get
it right i thought i was going to get
fired off of it so you know you got to
do you got to do that thing too where
you where your hand has to react to
nothing right totally totally um okay so
the mean bean is the best thing for a
coffee shop
so perfect i want to open a coffee shop
called the mean bean i'm going to steal
it
did you do any sort of
maybe you did some research into being
the perfect barista and sort of like
what's the key to the perfect coffee
well i think i think the key to the
perfect coffee is love
for sure okay know know who you're
making it for know what they like and
what they don't like
uh and and i think uh
also
um
i don't know i lost i lost my train of
thought there i think it's love i think
it's love i think i think i crush it on
the first one i was like i'm gonna give
them three and then i gave you two and i
was like
ah third one's not an option i guess
there we go you're making it with love
it can't take
[Music]
there you go that's why that's why i
lost it drop the mic on that one yeah um
so robotnik has a very fabulous
moustache in this film that even gets
its own slow-mo
he's embracing that you've got it going
on but you get the full beard right what
is the key
to the perfect beard and why is that the
perfect balance to the moustache
well i think it's uh it's classy you
know you've got again again it's that
element of robotnik is big and then
stone brings it down to some
groundedness so we have a nice tidy
beard versus the big wild mustache uh
and i think the key to a good beard is
shape
you gotta have those nice sliced edges
oh yeah and you totally did in the film
um what easter eggs are you excited if
you could maybe name one or two that
you're excited for fans to see in this
one because this movie to me feels like
a video game like it really yeah like
the video game whether or not you even
know the video game you can tell right
yeah they've
upped the stakes in terms of that well
100 percent uh i think is a great homage
and has so many nods to the video games
um oh man i can't
i can't specifically
say a single easter egg without feeling
like i'm going to ruin something what i
will say
is there's plenty and i think all the
fans are gonna love it
you